yeah how would you like to make 20
million dollars a year just for waking
up
that sounds pretty good hello we're
going to get to that story in a moment
as one of your favorite friends makes
his will and grace debut
david schwimmer david schwimmer how did
this happen how did you convince him to
come play with you
oh my gosh i don't know it really is
kind of a miracle
we're not getting ross gatlin not even
remotely it's such a wonderful story
between
his character noah and grace just
playing at the level
of this cast who are at the top of their
game it was kind of like this great
wonderful
gift we hate all the same things tv and
taxis
redhead got the worst okay so now that
david's here
the door's open does jen anderson come
courtney cox come
lisa kudra all of them what not oh my
gosh
i honestly think that people watching
would just like their heads would
explode
schwemmer is set to appear in five
episodes but let's get real here
he doesn't need the paycheck you're not
gonna believe this but david and his
five friends co-stars jennifer aniston
lisa cudro courtney cox matthew perry
and matt leblanc
each make a staggering 20 million
dollars a year
and syndication revenue from the show
friends ran for 10 years and we spent a
lot of time at the cast during its 236
episodes
and even though the series ended 14
years ago friends still makes about one
billion dollars a year
in syndication for warner brothers i
think we really lucked out